the time that you make a decision can
depend
the outcome of your destiny the
decisions you make today will determine
your tomorrow
just remember if you wait to make the
right decision
you waiting to reach your destiny
there should be a time in your life
where you say I'm tired of Phil I'm
tired of being let down I'm tired of
giving up
today is the day I will fight new
adversity
I will make
I will climb over this mountain
folks it ain't about that it ain't about
the guy who tries buying a clean car
when you're dirty it's not his fault
it's you should figure out how to be
clean you should figure out how to do a
job doesn't involve you walking in mud
all day and it's possible if somebody
else has done it but most of society
thinks biography is destiny
the past equals the future and of course
it does if you live it so really we go
to myself says decision is the ultimate
power that's what it really is I'm
always telling you how I went from one
spot to the next
spot and that was it like that listen to
me catch the first friend some old you
got it here you can't make a difference
until you make a decision
some of you men you keep cry you
complain about your job you complain
about where you are financially you
complain about your relationship you
complain about your opportunities you
complain it complaint it complaint it
listen to me you murmuring and
complaining you complaining and
complaining if you please shut up
stop complaining is in your favor if you
want to make a difference all you got to
do is one thing the decide you can start
it you want some did for it listen to me
all you got to do is make a decision
that's it there will never be a perfect
moment in your life to do something you
will always come up with excuses you
always say that the risk is too high you
will always say that now is not the time
get out of your comfort zone you will be
who you want to be at the other end of
it if you choose to go down the abyss
choose it what do you want to be
remembered for I hope you want to be
remembered as a grinder someone who
fights that way do all the things that
they go through do not give up on your
marriage do not give up in school do not
give up on your goals in your dreams you
want to be an athlete grind you want to
open up that company that organization
grind
nobody has to convince you to do what
you have to do
why is it that you deserve your goal
what are the five reasons that you won't
give up when I catch you on the Blind
Side when the messenger of misery visits
you what are you going to do what will
keep you in the game with life not you
to the campus
don't let anybody fool you into
believing that there's a guarantee that
there's a safe way the well-trodden path
is a serious way in my my opinion right
is then you just spent the last 80 years
of your life doing everything that
everybody else told you to do and you
never really lived will produce anything
unique
they're going this way go that way
devote yourself to an ideal